how i choose a profitable niche so on  one hand you might hear somebody say hey  i have a facebook ads agency and i would  hate to enter that business because  facebook's an aging platform the cost  per impression is going through the roof  it's more competitive than ever in terms  of the actual ad space and also the  amount of people that you're competing  against already established and have  already built out infrastructure to  outcompete you on the flip side one  degree separate would be having a  digital agency that does tick-tock or  does content for youtube shorts or  something those would be things that are  growing marketplaces that have lots of  space that are low-cost cpms that you  can get into early on and even though  the actual business of these two things  are the same the opportunity is vastly  different which is why i would go after  this one rather than the facebook agency